[موسيقى]
شكلك منذ دخولها الحرب العالميه الثانيه
مصدر القلق الاول لتيارين الامريكيين
المقاتله اليابانيه ميتسوبيشي اي 600 هذه
المقاتله التي اشتهرت بين الطيارين في
القوات الامريكيه بالاسم زيرو دخلت
المقاتله ميتسوبيشي الى الخدمه في العام
1940 اعتبرت حينها اقوى المقاتلات
الهجوميه هذا بسبب قدرتها الكبيره في
المناوره وكذلك تحليقها لمدى بعيد يصل الى
1870 كلم اول عملياتها العسكريه كانت في
الحرب الصينيه
حيث تمكنت اليابان بفضل هذه المقاتله من
تحقيق سيطره جويه لفتره مهمه من الحرب كما
شاركت ايضا بالهجوم الشهير على ميناء بيرن
هاربر الامريكي والحقت اضرار جزيلا
بالقوات الامريكيه الموجوده في الميناء في
هذا الوقت
تميزت ايضا المقاتله ميتسوبيشي اي 600
بقدرات الناريه كبيره حيث كانت مسلحه
بمدفعين رشاشين ثقيلين من عيار 20 مليمتر
وكذلك مدفعين اخرين من عيار 7.7 ملم هذا
بجانب قدرتها على حمل قنبلتين كل قنبله
تزن نحو 60 كجمرا لكن في اواخر يعني
1943 بدات موازين القوى تتغير لصالح
الحلفاء هذا بعد تمكن الشركات الامريكيه
من تطوير مقاتلات اسرع واقوى هذا الامر
افقد مقاتله الزيرو قوتها ورفع مستوى
خسائرها بشكل كبير الى ان خرجت من الخدمه
نهائيا في عام 1945
[موسيقى]